Hello, I'm Dr. Kevin Cutters, and I want to welcome you to this really
Introduction to what our stop-fighting cancer course is and why we put it together
That's my ugly bug down there in the corner
And this is really our kind of template for our clinic now our courses were really birthed off of
Really educating people. I have a lot of courses already
The stop-fighting cancer course is really our first one and that's really our flagship course
But after doing this fighting cancer course
I realized I needed courses on other things that we are providing like okay big pieces
You know dealing with cancer is to deal with detoxification
Maybe the live course really has the least to do with the stop-fighting cancer course
But if you're not dealing with detoxification, really understanding what I've written in my book
The seven phases of detoxification. If you're not really understanding those seven phases of detoxification
Really thoroughly you're gonna have a difficult time recovering from any disease
Cancer be one of them. So rather than making the stop-fighting cancer course so large that nobody can get through it
I created these other courses some people need detoxification that don't have cancer
Obviously, but certainly if you're going to do the stop-fighting cancer course already detoxification is key to that's it made that a course in itself
Certainly if you're going to be dealing with cancer you need to look at your genetics
That's a key component of what we've done for years. So we've actually created a course around that. We have you know
dozens of dozens of dozens of genetic videos that we've created to explain these genetic families and how dealing with them is
Crucial to getting better from any disease whatsoever
So that's another course in itself as well and then the frequency healing course
Oh, that ties into the stop-fighting cancer
Intimately for me because that's how I really got into helping people with a cancer diagnosis back in the 90s
Was my love for knife machines and knife technology now that has to do if you don't know what that means
You're going to learn about it in the book and you're going to learn about it in the stop-fighting cancer course
But the right technology is really what brought me into this is how God dragged me into the field of taking care of people with cancer quite honestly
It was my love for right technology that I learned about when I was in school in the early 1980s
And I was just you know in love with
What royal rife did and it's like I just felt in you know compelled to
To someday be able to help people using frequencies and it wasn't until the late 90s when a patient came in my office
With bilateral breast cancer and I tell that story multiple places
But that's really what brought me down that pathway and what really brought us to putting together
the stop-fighting cancer course which was our
First one that we put together was my book. So I wrote this book and a different cover
I think my first edition was maybe in 2010
2012 I can't remember and I wrote two editions following that this is our third edition
And our latest edition that I put together in 2020 it has here the 600 pages now the struggle with this is that
It's the right 600 pages good to say that's a lot of pages personally. I don't even like to read
You know, I was bored, you know with a reading dyslexia issue
It wasn't tell you know when I was in high school that I read my first book because I
Went to a practitioner or a car proctor who did kudiziology and did some acupuncture and found out that I had to look dyslexia
I couldn't read a book. I couldn't read a page
without you know not understanding and remembering anything I did
That's a story in itself, but
If that's how I went into this field of helping people because I was helped by somebody else
But I know that a 600 page stop-fighting cancer and start reading the cause book can be overwhelming to people
So we have to break this down. We have to break this down into pieces
We're discussing with the team. This is a couple years ago actually
We have to figure out how to break this down into a you know
Educational format that people can have bite-sized pieces and not just reading material but videos
I love making videos because I like to educate. That's really what I think my spiritual gift is is to be able to take complex
Concepts and break them down into pieces. So the average person can better understand them and more than that
Can utilize those concepts to make their life better and to me that's that's the key
This is my quote the gift of knowledge is a beautiful thing. Knowledge is wonderful
But knowledge in itself is a limited because it is the application of that knowledge that if you can't apply your knowledge
What good is that and I believe that wisdom is the application of knowledge and that can be life-changing
You know the Apostle Paul talked about this in detail in the New Testament
He said I think 19 times he said use the phrase brethren. I don't want you to be ignorant
Ignorance is not a good thing whether it's ignorance about scripture that can end up leading us to hell or
Ignorance of our body or ignorance of you know how to care for ourselves ignorance how to raise our children ignorance
How to have a good merit and ignorance how to have good relationships? That is not good
We are called to use this gray matter between our ears and I believe we have a responsibility to that
I mean Jesus spoke of this in parables that you know when too much who much is given much is
Expacted being God has given us so much and and we can ask for wisdom from him and ask for knowledge from him
But we have to do our part two you have to study to show yourself approved
It is it is not a good thing for you just to turn over your life to someone else
You know
In a spiritual sense, you know, I'm just gonna do what my pastor said and just trust him or her
Or you certainly in a medical sense. It's the same thing and of course
You know, I'm not function as your pastor, but I am functioning as a practitioner to an educator to give you information so that
You don't just turn over your
Personal power if you want to use that terminology to to a doctor to an oncologist have cancer
So I'm just gonna do everything my oncologist says well, then you know, that might not be a
Great thing, you know, I'd be good your oncologist cares about you. He wants here
She wants to do what's best for you, but is it right just to to turn over that responsibility of your health and your life and your future
To somebody else. I just don't think so. I don't think that's what God's calling us to do
I think we yes
We use doctors and we could use oncologists and we could use all their skill sets that they possess
But then we have to balance it out with doing our own study and doing our own research and looking at what we can add to this picture
You know, what what our responsibility on this is we're not to be ignorant
so
That's what this is all about. So I think that's what you're seeking otherwise
You wouldn't be listening to this video at eight minutes into it already
You are seeking information so that you can apply that information to better your life
To better your outcome
You have a cancer with a 30% five-year success rate meeting us 30 year 30% five-year survival rate by doing other things
Adding stuff that's in my book and that other great practitioners have have developed and
Produced you might double that you could have a 60% or 80%
Five-year survival rate and you could have a much more meaningful and better life and better outcomes
That's the whole idea. We're going to try to reproduce on college year
We're not trying to take the place of medicine. We're trying to
educate you so that you can
add to
Whatever God is pathway God is leading you down
That's the whole purpose. So in this stop fighting cancer course. I basically
Literally took my book broke it down into modules
Put it into transcripts put it into videos and audio for that that is
Literally a living course because I'm adding to it constantly and through that course through the modules
You will be able to walk through some steps that you could help yourself and feel like
That you got your power back that you're not just
Passing on the responsibility for your healing to someone else, but you are taking control back
And you feel like you could make your own more educated decisions
So there's seven modules the first one is about the natural when I call the natural band-aid approach. We don't want to just
You know cover up symptoms with supplements. We want to deal with some root cause things
Module two is what I've called the Conor's method because I literally share a video
I used to teach doctors
By method my cancer method
I gave that up years ago. It's like no, I just don't feel like that's my calling my calling was to help people
The lay population and to help them and I wanted to give my information to them
That's my stopped teaching doctors when I
wrote the second edition of my book
But I have a video of one of my seminars of teaching a doctor on that called the Conor's method
It walks you through a lot of steps that we look at when
That I believe that a cancer patient should look at and then module three is digging to find the cause now you can't
You know perfectly find the cause of your cancer, but there's a lot of reasons why people get cancer
There's always a reason why you have to ask yourself that question
I think it's foolish not to regardless of whether it's cancer or whatever it is. Why do I have this?
It's not because of you know
something that happened to you
meeting that like a genetic
precursor that now you have cancer because your mother had breast cancer and you're doomed to have breast cancer
There's a reason maybe it maybe you have cancer at your family because you all live in the same area
You're exposed to the same amount of toxins. You have the same genetic defects that you don't get rid of those toxins
And those toxins can settle in cells and damage the DNA and cause a rapid replication. That's what cancer is
But in this module we dig through that there's biotoxin causes causes toxic causes
Anything that could get inside the cell and damage the DNA and the replication cycle
Can be a cause of cancer. So in module three we dig into that
module four we start addressing the what do you do about it?
So I just call it address the cancer because we can't say treat the cancer
So what are you going to do specifically for your cancer?
And in there we have protocols that I have put together over doing this
I've been in practice for 35 years. I'm not practicing anymore
I'm dedicated my life to teach everything that I've done over the last 35 years in these courses
So I'm pouring my life into these courses
That's my wife. I still worked 10 hours a day
But now I'm taking that 10 hours a day and set it to eat one-on-one calls with people
I'm pouring my life into these courses everything that I know I'm addicted to studying and as I study
I'm taking those concepts and these things right in my best to break them down into
chewable morsels that you can take and better your life
Then module five I call it programming your life
But really I've expanded this module remember this is a living course
So this module is slowly becoming all sorts of different therapies that you could add at home
now
Years ago when we used to see patients in the office people came in and we used the knife and the pee of effing
and different tools on them
It would be a destination couldn't it like any clinic?
Because hey have a doctor and people come to me and they get care and they go home
But it was it was a number of years ago. I had a patient that had
bakery at a cancer with metastasis to the stomach the liver
I think it was the soft I guess I don't remember but he was given two weeks to live
By mail at that time we were practicing in Minnesota. He came to us two weeks to live
Given to him by mail and he looked at the part he was ash and gray
He did not look healthy. He was in his late later 70s
And um he started with us on the right. That's when we just saw people in the office again
And um he just slowly started getting better and getting better and getting better
Well kind of funny story about that was that he was only started with us after a week of care
He was starting to actually look a little bit better color
After that week and he said hey my son's coming up from california
His son linked in california and we're going hunting next week and I thought oh my goodness
Lauren what did he send me this person for it? Well
Maybe it's just for him to be able to go hunting with his son one more time
I'm okay with that you got to play on that's bigger than mine. I trust you in your sovereignty
Well, he came back into that week. Okay, I'm ready to start again and he just kept going to go
He just kept getting better and better in it about a year in his care
He said something like hey, I just want to let you know the removal to our house in um
california they had a winter place in california. We're gonna go there and
Do you know what anybody that has the right for practitioner that uses the right down there?
And that was literally one of those aha moments for me because I just prayed about lord
What am I supposed to do? What am I supposed to do with him, you know
And you know, I don't hear these audible voices, but I felt in my heart in my spirit that the lord just said
Well, what would you do if you had cancer? This is before I had cancer
So if you want to know my personal story go back to our website and hear my personal story with cancer, but
My answer back to the lord was well if I had cancer I'd have this at home and I'd be doing it every night while I'm sleeping
And I just felt his answer back was well, you should be doing this on everybody
So we just changed our whole plans. We stopped seeing you know gradually stopped seeing people in the office
Everything was at a distance. We just shipped program rights out to people and they started using the rights at home
And that's what we did for years
Now I don't practice at all one-on-one anymore
But we still program right machines. I've been doing right programming since the late 90s when we first got our right
I have a lot of experience in it. So
We have literally I have written programs for
probably every cancer that exists
So if you have cancer we program the right for you if you purchase a program right from us
That's a big piece of it in this module
We go over that
But again, I've expanded this module and talks about other therapies that you can have at home
I'm really big into having therapies at home if you can do that because
It's just you know
Think if you could only use it a couple hours a week or you could use it every single day
You know it's a big difference in the benefit of that therapy
And then module six is really cleaning up your environment not just your environment of
Your house or you know clean it up your your you know pesticides and chemicals use of your loan
But on your body environment your diet what should you be doing about your diet very specific diet pro dietary protocols are given in module four
But and here we go over just some details of a lot of people know a lot of this stuff in module six
But we just try to put it together of just hey you need to start being conscious of these things
Because these are the things that can cause disease cause cancer
And even if it's not a specific cause of cancer for you, it's certainly
toxins and chemicals and things in our environment
Decrease our immune response and anything that decreases our immune response increases the rate of cancer growth
And increases the the ability for cancer to metastasizing. We don't want that
But then module seven is cancer can't kill you if you're already dead
And this is my spiritual take on cancer and God's sovereignty
But more than that, it's dealing with the emotional aspect of having a serious disease
But again, I personally have gone through this and so I can personally speak to that and I
recommend you go back to my personal story
There's really dark days in my personal story that I was convinced I think it was three years ago
That I was not going to see Christmas and
I was prepping my family and talking to my kids, you know, we have 20
grandkids now
And you know at that time maybe we had 14 or 15 or something
But I was really prepped mentally that hey, this is the way God's going to take me home
And so be it but I'm going to serve him up to the day I die
Did I feel miserable at a regular basis on that but that's my desire
So I go over this an emotional spiritual aspect in module seven. I understand
This is the course. This is the stop fighting cancer course
Um, it goes beyond that
So, you know from our stop fighting cancer course, you know, it's packed with all this information
You can then purchase a fully program right which
I program so and with the fully program right you get the frequency healing course
You could purchase other beneficial tools that I teach about as well
So different hyperthermia, EMF machine or
Saunas and different things like that coffee and animal equipment all these different things that I teach about
We have that you can get from us if you want
Now you could purchase a full genetic review. That's a key component and I talk a lot about that
And again, I've created a course about that. You could free access to the read your genes course
And we go over your full genetic review from a cancer perspective
Um, and with that full genetic review you get, you know, a full breakdown of what we think
Would be action steps based upon your genes
or this is what
Most of uh, people most people do when they do the course
They add our full private membership
Now again, I'm not in practice any longer. I don't do one-on-one calls
Um, but it's through our full private membership that you have access to me
We do weekly group zoom calls actually we're doing two a week right now
So you can jump out our protocol zoom call you can jump out our weekly Q&A zoom call
Through the full uh membership you have full access to our members only site and on the members only site
That's where you can put in questions for the zoom call and that's where you have
It's a full expanded site
So through that site you have access to all of my nutritional and dietary protocols
specific for your cancer type
Um, and it's not just one, you know, because something might work and it stops working
So I have multiple protocols for these cancers
Um, this is based on my experience and be prayed about these protocols and asking God to give me wisdom and to break down that wisdom and to
Useful bite-sized pieces
You have access to literally hundreds. I think I have
Ah, I think God's count was 900 blog posts and articles that you could have access to and they're indexed
So you can search they're all searchable
I want to know about aromatase inhibitors. You can type in that search bar aromatase inhibitors and boom
You're going to find three or four articles on aromatase inhibitors and the best ones to use for what thing
You're going to have access to all our summits and master classes
You're going to have access to all my old Q&A video library which is a huge library
And all our youtube videos that are exclusive to our course or our membership
Um, as you can't get on our youtube channel
Um, because they just won't let us put them there
And you have access to all our other health courses
So the frequency healing course the genes course all those courses are free to our full members
So that our comprehensive membership is basically everything on here
So you get the right fishing you get the
Um genetic review and you get the full private membership
So remember
I believe in teaching
How to use things right
So if a person purchases a rife machine for us that's why I created the frequency healing course because
I don't want you
I mean, I think the worst thing that I see in life is somebody like purchases a treadmill and it becomes
Something that they hang their clothes on right we have these great ambitions
We're going to use this tool for the betterment of our life
And we don't it's too hard. We have too tired. I'll do it tomorrow
Well, I'm guilty of that too
But I certainly know what anybody guilty of that when they purchase a rife machine for me
Because if you're going to purchase a rife machine for me
It comes with all of my years of experience to create those programs and to put them together for you for you to use
Believe me over the years. I've gotten rife machines back from a family member of a person who died
And I have a way of looking up on the
On the log to see how many times they use it and they've had it for six months and used it four times
That is just a crying shape. That's just to be that's just sad. It's just really sad. Don't
You're not going to let that happen to you. So I actually put together that course. It's got
I think the frequency healing course has got
Salved modules same as this by the cancer course with how to use this any
You know q&a's tons of videos
How to use it for your family for other things how to use it for your kids
Most of my adult kids have them to use have a rife machine at home to use for
Their kids my grandkids
So they got a cold or something run the rife on the cold and flu
You use a tool that's only as good as you can use it
So that's why I put together that course same thing with the genes
A lot of people go run their genetics and then they have somebody go over it that
Sorry, they just don't know what they're doing. So um, I don't want that to be your excuse for
Taking that data and applying it. So I put together a read your genes course
Now that is four modules, but module three is packed full of videos just about every gene family that exists
So you will be fully equipped plus we don't just give you the readout
Because it comes with your genetics it comes with like a 250 plus page readout that is like oh my word
What are we gonna do with this?
So we break it out and we give you two other reports that we've created
That tell you what I think are the most specific gene families that you need to address and you need to deal with
And then another report that's called our action steps report is here's some things you should do
There's some dietary things you should follow here some nutritional things you should follow here
You need to consider these things
Key component you gotta you gotta make use of the data that you get right?
So breaking it down into pieces where you could use it and it becomes
beneficial to you
That's that's what this court is all about right and I listed the full private membership out before
But it is literally a private member site with
Everything you could think of now. This is only for cancer
So the private member site is not for live disease or not for
You know somebody who just wants to detox mercury and it's important, but it's only for cancer
This is our private cancer member site
So again, you know our desire and our heart is to constantly be asking why why do I have this
What is going on? How am I going to deal with this?
Asking better questions. I think it's the key to having better success
Better what you're doing right and
I've stressed it over and over again, but it is literally the application of knowledge that is wisdom
And that's what's going to change our lives and that's my hope in prayer for you
You know our bottom line is that
You know, I want to share and I feel like you know what my calling is is to teach
That's why we getting out of private practice so that I could teach a greater number of people
Was the best thing that God did we forced my hand in some ways
But this is my calling is to share
What I can learn and to give it to you in ways that
You can make positive changes in your life. That's our prayer to you
I just really hope that this course is a blessing and
Everything that we do could be a blessing
Long in the future and in the long after I've gone. That's our prayer. Thanks